So from a dominant pedigree's perspective, we
find that affected parents have affected children,
and the trait does not skip generations. If we look at the pedigree over here,
we know that unaffected parents don't have
affected children. Notice that there's no scenario over
here, where a child has unaffected parents,
instead. Every child that's affected has affected parents.
And as far as skipping generations go. I mean, you can
see on both sides of the pedigree, of the family tree
here, that we have affected
great grandparents, affected grandparents, affected parents,
and then affected children. So the trait does not skip generations.